call of duty black ops cold war is set
between black ops 1 and 2.
it's a sequel to the original not a
reboot like last year's modern warfare
and given that it's been 10 years since
black ops
i'll bet you forgot a bunch of what
happened in that game
so this video is going to boil down the
plot to get you ready for black ops cold
war
what do they mean i don't know anything
about any numbers
the main story of black ops when you
reduce all the noise and flashing
numbers
the plot of call of duty black ops 1 is
pretty straightforward
it's a story about a man undergoing two
competing
brainwashing programs one to work for
russia
and kill an american president and the
counter programming to kill the russian
military leaders
responsible for the brainwashing in the
first place the entire rest of the story
is just about who he does and doesn't
[Music]
kill
and now
the players alex mason a cia officer
is captured in cuba after a failed
attempt on the life of fidel castro
during the bay of pigs the bay of pigs
was a real-life botched operation to
train cuban exiles
and land them back in cuba to overthrow
castro black ops built off of the
military disaster that ensued and in its
story
castro sets up a trap to capture
high-level americans
who could get close to key american
leaders mason is taken and sent to a
russian labor camp called vorkuta
in order to be made into a sleeper agent
through an experimental brainwashing
program
run by russian major general nikita
dracovich dragovich's plan is to send
sleeper agents back to the united states
and trigger them at the right time to do
very bad things
like kill the president the
pre-programmed trigger is to be
broadcast
off of a ship called rusalka through a
series of mysterious numbers
mason you want the numbers mason that's
all we've ever wanted
mason ends up being very resistant to
the brainwashing program
and at one point is given up as a
failure that's when victor reznoff
who fought for russia during world war
ii and was betrayed by dragovich
makes his move he messes with mason's
programming and sends him to kill his
own rivals
dracovich
all must die by the end of black ops 1
reznov seems to have come out on top
sort of mason kills both the nazi
scientists diner
and the russian commander dragovich but
it is heavily implied
although not confirmed that he may have
also been involved in killing president
john f
kennedy which was his original
programming it's also very likely that
victor reznov
never actually made it out of the labour
camp for kuta and he died at this moment
in the story and only lives on in
mason's head
i guess that's one way of not having to
pay for gary oldman to come back
on the ledge shoot him
what you need to know for black ops cold
war now black ops 1 takes place between
1961
and 1968. we recently got to see a
single-player presentation for black ops
cold war and the developer said that we
would be returning
to 1968 vietnam and lao where we would
relive a memory over and over again
recalling new details to uncover the
truth about a russian super spy named
perseus
who will be the main villain of cold war
there are a few
very interesting loose ends from the
black ops 1 story that takes place in
that year
for starters frank woods a main
character who you fight alongside in
black ops 1 is presumed dead
in 1968 after saving your life
we know from later black ops games that
he was actually captured
and sent to the infamous torture prison
known as the hanoi hilton
we never learned how he actually managed
to escape but we do know that he was
then moved to da nang
as a prisoner of war until at least
1972.
kravchenko who was on the list of people
mason was supposed to kill is still
alive he's mostly been built as a
comically evil character
and there's a lot of room for him to
grow and become more important
in cold war flashbacks and during our
time with the single player presentation
we also saw flashbacks to nazis in world
war ii
it's highly possible that the plot may
return to the currently deceased
friedrich steiner
a captured nazi scientist instrumental
in the vorkuta brainwashing program
and who also developed an extremely
dangerous chemical weapon
called nova 6. now nova 6 is still in
play and is a recurring threat
throughout the black ops series
that continues past the timeline of the
cold war game
nova 6 was just one of the sleeper
operations but i'm sure there were
others
ones we didn't even know about what we
know about cold war's plot
the main part of cold war takes place in
1981 which is 13 years after black ops 1
and the failure of the numbers program
however the soviet union hasn't given up
plotting to bring down
america and have leaned into a long-term
strategy that
takes decades this was revealed in the
know your history trailer as
active measures which has phases
including demoralize
destabilize create crisis and then
normalize
a soft government takeover part of this
program involves sabotaging and stealing
military assets and we know one of the
main antagonists perseus
is running around stealing nuclear
secrets and trying to keep russia's
nuclear program one step ahead of the
united states
it's your job to try and stop them in
the meantime russia is still training to
invade the united states by building
mock towns
and practicing assaults on them although
mason woods and jason hudson are in cold
war
a cast of new characters seem to be the
ones hunting perseus
including a cia officer named russell
adler
lead writer murray craft said that
players are supposed to question his
intentions
and we know the game has multiple
endings so we might be looking at an
unreliable
narrator so where do you think the cold
war story is gonna go
and where it might circle back on loose
ends in black ops one
let us know in the comments below and if
you want to learn more about cold war
check out our extensive
everything you need to know video thanks
for watching
[Music]
you